hey guys how's it going so one of my
favorite things to watch on TV or movies
or anything is is zombie shows I love
them so much I'm kind of slightly
obsessed so obsessed the fact that I got
this
Sega's Omni emergency kit so in case
there was a zombie outbreak you haven't
noticed I'm actually traveling so I'm
your hotel right now if I were traveling
and there's a zombie apocalypse or
something I needed to protect myself I
thought this would be the perfect thing
for protection it says right here it's a
zombie outbreak survival kit first thing
that I notice is something this small I
don't think you can really protect you
from absolutely anything maybe a paper
cut you want a paper cut zombie cuz it's
wall I'm gonna be able to do with this
packet the problem is there's so many
different types of zombies you can't be
prepared to fight them all no say myself
there's no way so I watched this trailer
of this show called iZombie which I was
like whoa okay
izombie iJustine completely makes sense
in the show this girl live she works at
a morgue she somehow became a zombie
because she went to a party than she got
scratched now she is undead but what is
crazy is she doesn't actually seem like
a zombie and that's where I'm kind of
getting a little bit a little bit
nervous but if there's people walking
around right now that are actually
zombies when she eats someone's brain
she works in a morgue so obviously she
has access to brains totally normal she
gets visions from this person's brain
and that completely just creeps me out
like I and I'm not okay with that
to grow you stay back anyway let's unbox
this I'm really excited to see the show
it starts March 17th at 9 o'clock on the
CW and let me tell you what I will be
the first one watching it because I need
to know how to protect myself first
steps first in our zombie survival kit
to protect myself from live oh my god
it's it's a cd-rom it's a freaking
cd-rom is this gonna protect me from
anything anything that this is gonna do
is be completely worth it so because my
computer currently does not even have a
place that I can even stick this what's
this this looks like Oh perfect
some caution tape what am I gonna do
this will just let me tell other people
that hey caution
there's a zombie outbreak happening
caution caution worthless what's next oh
this is a toe tag what's this gonna do
absolutely nothing we have next why this
is gonna be super freakin helpful some
cards this will not do anything
pardon me zombie can you please back up
cuz I've got some playing cards here it
might be a little bit dangerous I know
you're quite afraid of this one aren't
you you are not gonna save my life what
else do we have in here emergency use
only this is a bite kit Scott
sterilizing wipe a gauze pad in a cotton
swab this little tree q-tip this is not
gonna do anything oh pardon me zombie
maybe I could clean out your ear maybe
you've got a little speck of makeup here
that's not gonna do anything that's not
gonna save a life Oh a sterilizing gauze
pad does this is just this is not even I
can't even I literally can't even I'm
not sure if you guys have ever seen
zombie bites before but let me tell you
what honey
this ain't cuttin it it says right here
everything that I need to survive a
zombie infestation oh god I think I got
the best bet is probably to become
friends with live this uh-huh
Oh hallelujah we have we've got a pin
maybe I'll wear this on my jacket just
to let everyone know that
like shut up we're getting into really
really good stuff
we've got stickers there's a there's
been a zombie outbreak Oh can't you see
can't you see this stickers all over if
you're a zombie this is gonna stop you
from doing anything no you guys not know
how this works
Oh zombie disposal unit this is just
absolute loader Chris it's so upset
really thought I was gonna be able to
survive Oh hold on we've got some more
paper I will oh great okay here you guys
don't know anything you don't know
anything this is the most disappointing
thing that I've ever oh okay this is a
lot of text this is a lot of text you're
not going to survive so you should
probably prep and learn the text prior
to a prior to set infestation absolutely
unbelievable well guys uh that's it
if you were thinking about making a
zombie survival kit what things would
you put in the kit I'll tell you what
things not to put in the kit anything
that I've just mentioned in this video
anyway that's it
izombie premieres March 17th 9 8 central
I'll definitely be watching it because I
feel like I might have a new favorite
show I'm gonna go because I now have to
clean up everything that I just threw my
room
this is I am I'm in shock right now
absolute shock you cannot call yourself
a zombie survival kit because what you
can call yourself you could call
yourself a lie